okay hi everyone
welcome to another episode of science
and technology q
a for kids and others uh happy
thanksgiving weekend to people in the
u.s um
it's a
day for me where i get to work on lots
of things i don't usually work on so
this is in the middle of me working on
um a bit of a science uh project that's
been a spin-off from our physics project
but um
anyway happy to be here to answer
questions and
so on so there were a few left over from
last week that i saw here
um this woman from purkinje
our instruction set architecture is
important for simulating physical
systems
and how could they change the way kids
understand computers
okay that's an interesting question so
when when we use a computer
we're usually using it not
at a sort of native level of what the
designers of the computer
imagined were i had set up as the
low-level instructions of the computer
but instead we're using application
programs which are many many many layers
above
what the actual computer has as its
intrinsic programming so for example
when we click a mouse
in a window on a computer that's
initiating
millions of of actual operations that
are going on in the cpu of the computer
each of those operations in the cpu of
the computer
is represented by some number some op
code that says what kind of operation
it's going to be
some operands that say what the
operations are on so you know you click
your mouse
and there'll be this whole cascade of
things that happen what what are those
low-level
operations that the computer does well
there'll be things like
here's a piece of data that is stored in
the memory of the computer
move it to some other place in the
memory of the computer or
there's a number stored somewhere in the
memory of the computer add one to it
those are the kinds of things that exist
as the kind of lowest level operations
those are the things when you build a
cpu chip those are the things
that are built into the cpu chip those
are the built-in machine instructions
that the cpu chip does and there have
been different sort of trends at
different times in the history of making
cpu chips
one important trend that pretty much
took over is the so-called risk
idea the reduced instruction set
computer idea
and kind of the idea was uh people it
got to the point where there were like
thousands of
of different intrinsic instructions
built into the operation of the computer
that would do things like
oh take the bits and a number and rotate
them around and do this and do that
lots of lots of very specific operations
or take these three numbers and
add them together and put the result
multiplied by two in this place
those you know there were elaborate
things like that that were machine
instructions
individual instructions executed by the
cpu of the computer
then there was sort of a trend in the
what was it in the
80s to 1980s 1990s the
this idea of reduced instruction set
where the idea was
just have a a very a fairly small number
maybe tens
of different possible instructions that
the computer does
and if you want to do these other
instructions you can always
represent them in terms of sequences of
these simpler instructions
and so the notion was just make those
simpler instructions absolutely as
efficient as possible
and then set it up so that these more
complicated things you want to do
get compiled into those simpler
operations now in the end
that's what you're going to have to do
anyway because in the end
when you write a program when you have
that thing that says what to do when you
click your mouse
in the end you're compiling some
some program some set of operations that
you describe something you want to have
happen you're compiling it down to this
low level machine code
so there's sort of a question of is it
better to
have the compiler try to optimize how it
does that compilation
into a small set of of simple
instructions or is it better to have
a bigger set of of uh intrinsic
instructions
that are each optimized just by virtue
of the way the hardware works
it's turned out it's typically better as
is usually the case it's easier to do
things with software
than by ch by by setting up the
underlying hardware so it turns out to
be easier and better
to just have this simple set of
instructions that the computer can do
and then have uh use software to find
optimum ways
to sort of compile what you want down
into those instructions
but so the question would be well how do
you pick those instructions
you know i have i have uh one friend in
particular who's
who's a who's essentially an instruction
set designer
is is like deciding what instructions
would
are the right ones to pick as the lowest
level kind of things
is it an instruction that for example
takes an array of numbers
and does something to all of them is it
an instruction that does this what are
those correct low-level instructions
in a sense it's like an activity that
i've spent a very long time on which is
a computational language design uh but
it's at a
it's a sort of a lower level than that
because here's what here's what's going
on
the when i think about computational
language design and things like design
of our orphan language
um the the thing that i'm thinking about
is how do i take something that a human
thinks about
and um uh something about i don't know
computing distances between cities and
finding minimums of this and that and
the other how do you take something that
you think about and
in the best possible way express it
computationally
so that you can have a computer help you
with it that's kind of the role of
computational language
in um uh is is to make that bridge
between the way we think about things
and the way that a computer can do
computations with them
now traditional programming languages
you know the c java
python world that have been concerned
with a different kind of thing they've
been concerned with
there are certain things the computer
does how do we set it up so that
as well as possible uh we humans can cut
sort of define
what sequence of operations that the
computer intrinsically does
we would what like the computer to do
how do we how do we set it up so that we
say
uh the computer might have an operation
that uh says
you can you can add one to a number you
can you can execute this
instruction you can keep going and you
can loop around if if some condition
happens if some number is less than zero
or something then you say jump to this
other instruction
so then a programming language would
define something which intrinsically
says
there's this loop and when you reach
this particular point
jump back to this point the concept of
sort of a computational language is
you're not really thinking about
loops and program counters and so on and
so on and so on
you're thinking about kind of as much as
possible things in the way that we
humans think about them so it might just
be you've got this whole
list of things do something to all of
them not make a loop that says do
something to this one then do something
with this one then do something to this
one
even though the do something to this
then this then this then this that loop
is what intrinsically at the lowest
level the computer is ultimately going
to do but sort of the idea of a
computational language
is at least my idea of computational
language is
to define something which as much as
possible captures the way humans think
about things
and then it's the job of the language
designer that's us in the particular
case of
language to convert that representation
of the way people think about things
into something that is kind of the um
the low level of what one can implement
on a computer okay so that's the role of
computational language
human thinking converts it to something
that
is uh rep that can be executed
computationally
the role of designing an instruction set
for a computer
is something a little different the role
there is to say
uh the the target is not a human the
target
is the compiler that takes programs
humans have written
and sort of converts them to some
low-level operations
the target is can you make a bridge
between the things that you build into
the hardware
and the things that your compiler
can take programs that have been created
in some other way
and and convert them into that low level
instruction set
so it's kind of like what and then the
question is what
what choice of instructions uh are such
that you can you can optimize those
instructions
and have the most efficient kind of way
of things being compiled to those of
those
instructions and so it's a whole
separate art form a different activity
from computational language design is
this design of sort of optimal uh
instruction sets and and things get very
tricky because
when you start thinking about
instruction sets and how to design them
and so on
there are all kinds of questions about
oh i don't know something like
um uh what will be
you might have a sequence of operations
that are being done and you might have a
very fast piece of computer memory
that's very close to where
the actual operations get done in the
cpu of the computer
and you might have questions about can
you pre-fetch the
the pieces of data that you're going to
need in those operations
so they're right there ready when that
operation is going to be done
it's one kind of thing or can you say
things like much more extreme craziness
at some level
uh you know let's say that a zero is the
absence of an electrical
of electrons in some particular place
and a one is the presence of electrons
can you use the fact that if you can
mostly deal with zeros and not too many
ones
there will be different electrical
properties of something that allow you
to run the thing just a little bit
faster
those are the kinds of things you think
about in kind of designing an
instruction set
that kind of goes from the intrinsic
physics
of the semiconductor chip to
the kinds of things that that a a
compiler uh something which takes uh
sort of a a program and turns it into
machine code
something that a compiler can emit how
does how do you sort of optimally
connect those two things together so
it's sort of the bridge
between the physics of the
microprocessor and
the um and the things that a compiler
can emit as it grinds up a program that
somebody wrote
to make it so that it can be executed in
terms of those machine instructions
so now the question is how do you change
what what is the best choice of that set
of instructions
to be able to run different kinds of
programs in the best possible way
so for example if you know that the
programs are going to be running
involve doing uh operations on
huge arrays of data so for example
things to do with images things to do
with sounds things to do with video
you kind of know there's going to be
this whole giant array of pixels for
example in dealing with an image
and you're going to want to do things
that whole array of pixels
um and so having an instruction set
that is sort of optimized to deal with
kind of long vectors of things
that tends to be something that is good
uh if if you are expecting that you're
dealing with images and videos and
things like that
and and for example in current times
uh gpus graphics processing units um
they have been set up to deal with these
big arrays of things
that were originally of importance in
doing uh in just dealing with graphics
um and dealing with these arrays of
pixels and so on but turn out to also be
really convenient
in dealing with things like artificial
neural nets where you have these huge
sort of collections of of uh connections
and matrices representing them and so on
um that similarly i sort of just take
all these
all these arrays of numbers and operate
on them in parallel
so the question is what can one do if
one's
if one is running certain kinds of
programs how can one optimize
the sort of uh instruction set that one
builds into one's computer so remember
the instruction set is this kind of
bridge between the physics of how the
computer works
and the things a compiler will produce
as here are the things i want to do
um so in a sense both of those things
are worth thinking about in terms of how
you build the right instruction set
if you change the physics of how the
computer works that's one thing
if you change the kinds of computations
that you want to do the kinds of things
that a compiler will be emitting
that's another kind of thing and and
both are of interest
because for example the the sort of the
rise of artificial neural nets and so on
brought in a whole nother set of
operations that people routinely wanted
to do on computers
that they hadn't been interested in
before and so that
that sort of tilts some of the things
that you want to optimize about the
instruction set
uh another thing by the way is is
thinking about how much power the
computer is going to use
and what kinds of operations you know if
like you might use more power to deal
with ones and zeros and things like that
and you get very very detailed
in figuring out sort of how to optimize
the way that the computer is set up or
you might it might matter how many when
you're doing multiplication
it's like do you really need to do
multiplication with all
with 16 digits of precision or for the
particular operation you're doing and
processing an image or doing something
with a neural net
are three digits of precision sufficient
and can you sort of drop down
dynamically to only doing that
well okay so so
i think one of the things that uh you
might wonder
is okay in principle at a theoretical
level
what is the minimum instruction set that
you could possibly need
to make a computer work well this is
something i happen to have spent lots of
time studying
and one of the big surprises is that the
kind of
the set of instructions that you need to
be able to do arbitrary computations
is incredibly small it's much smaller
than any practical thing that people use
for computers
um in fact i just been studying a lot
something which is about to have its
100th anniversary the idea of things
called combinators
uh combinators just these two things
like two instructions in some sense
usually called s and k you put them
together in all kinds of different
possible ways
they're very hard for us humans to
understand but you put them together
and you can show that you can do any
computation with just this whole
giant program made from nested s's and
k's and so on
well the same thing is true uh i've
studied a lot cellular automata where
one just has
uh arrays of sort of black and white
cells and and you just
update them according to the what the
neighboring colors of cells are and so
on again
very very simple setup a rule that you
can state in one sentence you can write
it down in
in you know a tiny tiny space uh it's
uh you know very simple to state the
rule it's in a sense a very very simple
instruction set yet it turns out
sort of a big surprise it's actually
something that's sort of a result of a
bunch of
science that i've done is the big
surprise is that even when
these uh instruction sets in a sense are
extremely simple
as soon as the instruction set is pretty
much capable of doing quotes anything
interesting
anything not trivial it will turn out
that the instruction set
is capable of letting you create any
program you want
so in other words you can take something
like these combinators you can take
something like one of these simple
cellular automata
and you can say um you know with an
appropriate program with an appropriate
way of setting it up to
what how the way it starts its operation
will compute anything you want to
compute it can work out prime numbers it
can do this
it can do that it can do any of these
computations that you want
now sometimes it can be difficult to
compile
from some description in some higher
level language to compile it down
to something that can be run in terms of
a cellular automaton or combinators or
whatever else
that can be a difficult piece of
compilation but once you've figured out
how to do it
you just rerun that compiler again and
again and again you can always do it
sometimes and
and often one of the things that's a
little bit confusing is you might think
that the lower level the instructions
are the bigger more complicated a
program you need to have
to execute a particular kind of thing
turns out this is often not the case
i don't think we really understand
scientifically just
how to think about that because really
what it is it's a question of
if you say well of all possible programs
how long do they need to be for when we
think about all possible programs
but that will have one answer but the
real answer we want is
let's look at all the programs we care
about all the programs we actually want
to write
and ask how long will they be when we
try and compile them down
we don't really have a great way to
think about that i've spent some time
trying to figure out how one might think
about that but but um
in any case the the um so the point is
you can uh we don't really know how
difficult it is to compile
things down to these very low level very
simple
sort of foundations for computation that
i as i should emphasize
are vastly simpler than the kinds of
instruction sets that are implemented in
current microprocessors
why do you care about even simpler
instruction sets here's one good reason
let's say you want to compute things at
the level of molecules let's say you
want to do a computation where instead
of having
you know 100 000 electrons representing
every bit of data
you just want one electron representing
every bit of data you just want
you want the the computation you you're
doing to actually be operating at the
level of
little pieces of molecules moving around
and they represent
the computation you're doing you can you
can kind of read off a number by just
looking at
the way that the atoms in a molecule are
arranged or something like this
if you want to do that if you want to
make a computer that's built
at the scale of individual molecules
then compiling down to
instructions in quotes that are much
simpler than the ones we use for current
microprocessors
is an interesting thing to try to do
people haven't worked as much as they
should have done
on those kinds of ideas um i think
that's something we'll sort of see in
the in the future um it's kind of an
evolution of ideas about chemistry
chemistry is
is all about looking at molecules and
seeing how they interact that's
what chemical reactions are and and
seeing how you can change a molecule
by by sort of having it uh interact with
other molecules
but in any case that's that's one kind
of direction you know a lot of people
talk a lot about quantum computing
um let me not get into the the full
details of that here
right now but but essentially what's
being done there is to think about
other kinds of physics which could be
used to make
computational things our current
microprocessors
all work on one idea they all work on
the idea
of making uh using semiconductors
things that are sort of between metals
that conduct electricity really easily
and insulators that don't really conduct
electricity at all semiconductors
kind of sometimes conduct electricity
when the conditions are right
and by by sort of setting things up
so that you can sort of choose whether
the conditions are right or wrong you
can kind of make a switch
and in the end that's how our computers
are made they're just that whole
collection of transistors
which represent switches and there might
be a billion of them on a modern cpu
chip
um and uh the um but but that's but the
idea is to use semiconductors
and use electrical signals and
semiconductors and that's the way all
our microprocessors all our computers
that we use in practice work but um
there are quite different ideas
that one thinks about in quantum
computing whether it's um
looking at um the uh looking at little
tiny quantized pieces of
magnetic flux um whether it's looking at
um
uh the arrangement of individual um
atoms that are representing uh little
tiny magnets and so on
a variety of different kinds of physics
that one tries to use
as sort of a different foundation for uh
for creating a computational thing
and and then we now know how to make
compilers actually we've just made some
very recent advances
in doing that using our models of
physics making efficient compilers
two different kinds of sort of quantum
hardware
um but but those are other kinds of
ideas about how to make computers
and and no doubt there can be sort of
breakthroughs
in in what computers are made of because
computers have been made of
semiconductors
uh basically since the 1960s um
and uh uh the the you know we that
the underlying physics of computers
hasn't really changed
the size of the of the of the little
components has gotten
much smaller it's a big engineering
effort um but the fundamental idea
hasn't changed and
um the the kind of the choice of
instruction sets
is is uh somewhat determined by the
particulars
of that particular technology and the
fact that it involves switches and
uh and logic gates and so on and so on
and so on
so uh and the question of whether
whether we can make
a computer that um uh has very different
underlying physics and it'll be really
good for some particular purpose it's an
interesting question we don't really
know the answer to it yet
one thing you might say is well if you
want to simulate a physical system let's
say you want to
figure out how all these molecules you
know you have a bunch of molecules
flopping around
and you want to figure out how these
molecules are going to arrange
themselves and so on
maybe you could make a computer that is
more like a bunch of molecules itself
that would be more efficient at doing
that than the computers we have today
there's sort of a whole tradition of
computing from the 1940s and 1950s
so-called analog computing in which
instead of
using bits digital data um one was
instead just using electric currents and
so on
where it's like well relevant stain we
either have a bit or we don't have a bit
we either have a
um we have a this an individual digital
we don't
it's like well we have a voltage of
3.742
we have some continuous range of
voltages
and there was some success in making
analog computers
that sort of work would correspond to
actual systems in the world that sort of
obeyed the same mathematical equations
as the analog computers the real problem
was that programming
the idea that you can kind of represent
any computation
by some appropriate sequence of a fixed
set of instructions
nobody ever figured out how to do that
for analog computers nobody ever figured
out
kind of a a something like a programming
language for analog computers
it's actually an interesting math
problem because it has to do with uh and
again
going a little bit too much more
sophisticated but but when you think
about mathematical functions
uh you know x squared x cubed log x
square root of x those kinds of things
for any value of x
you get a result and the question is are
there
sort of universal functions where you
can say i've just got this fixed set of
functions
and by putting them together in the
right way i'll create any function i
want
there's much less understood about that
than there should be and that's a
kind of an interesting thing i don't
think it's implementable in our universe
since we now believe that we actually
have a pretty good idea
how fundamental physics works i think i
can fairly with fairly good authority
say
that uh you know that would be an
interesting thing to study
mathematically
but our actual universe can't implement
that at least not perfectly
but it still might be of interest to
understand how that works
both in terms of the mathematics and
because one might be able to approximate
it's
its implementation in the actual
universe all right that was a much
longer
um uh answer than uh
than i expected to give there um
let's see um
boy
all kinds of questions here
um
okay the question about um from a toure
how much do you follow your instincts
how do you develop a good instinct
in science and in life it's an
interesting question
um you know what does it mean one's
instincts
in a sense it's i i would say that the
um
uh it's like what can you say i
immediately know the answer and what do
you have to say let me
try and figure out the answer in a bunch
of steps
what requires kind of figuring stuff out
versus what's like oh i kind of know
what the answer is
and and sometimes it's what can i
explain the steps
versus what do i just say believe me
this is the right answer
you know i think the principle thing as
far as i'm concerned
is when a situation confronts itself
uh you know what i'm really doing i
think first and foremost
is saying you know what's a thing like
this that i run into before
and what happened or what did i figure
out in that case
and you know i happened to be lucky
enough to have a pretty good
memory so it's uh that really helps
in sort of developing instincts because
it's like that means that i have a
pretty good inventory
of oh i've seen something like this
before this is how things are going to
work in this case
now i think the the how do i make a
match between something i've seen before
and something i'm seeing now a very
important piece of that
i think is have i really managed to
break down
what happened or what i saw into the
most fundamental components that is
let's say i see something at some piece
of math it does this thing it says some
complicated thing
it's like what's intrinsically going on
there if i can figure out sort of a very
low level what's intrinsically going on
there's a much better chance
that when i see something again that it
will match at that intrinsic level even
if the details even if one thing is
about
you know higher category theory and
another thing is about um
i don't know the theory of combinators
or something um if
uh uh two very elaborate areas of
mathematics but but
um uh you know if i if i have understood
at a sort of low level oh that thing
about higher category theory i can think
of it
in terms of graphs which i understand
quite well and this thing i can think of
the same
way if i if i manage to break both of
those things down into these sort of
primitive elements then then i can kind
of immediately make that match between
them and if if my way of understanding
them
it's the thing i remember about how
higher category theory works
is the thing about graphs which i kind
of understand you know sort of a lower
level thing
then it's it's uh if that's the way i
remember it
then it's much easier to say oh that's a
match to this
new thing that i'm thinking about which
i can also break down in the same way so
i suppose
the important part is you know how do
you make sure that the things that you
know about
that you kind of understand in the
simplest possible way in terms of the
simplest possible
sort of components so that you can more
readily
make a match with new things that you're
confronted with and i think that that's
some
uh it's kind of a you know just you know
it really helps to know more stuff
and to have seen more things it also
really helps to have a kind of a
a habit of trying to connect one thing
to another
because once you have that habit sort of
things start chaining together
and you start being able to have this
kind of bigger lake of
of ideas that you can then draw on uh
when the next thing comes in
now you know can one apply those that
type of thinking
not only to science but also to life and
not only to
you know that there there are so many of
these things where it's where it's all
about um uh
well it's all about things once seen
before you know i'm writing a program
the program doesn't work
the you know something goes wrong well
it's like well i've seen something like
that before
or there's some bizarre computer systems
problem
and it's like well i've seen something
like that before and i remember
you know 10 years ago i ran into
something like that and it turned out to
be this
let's go poke at that um that's kind of
the uh
you know an important part of the
instinct about what's going on sometimes
there's a question of whether uh you
know what
well another issue is when you look at
different domains
there's a question of how do you develop
instincts for those different domains
and how do you know when your instincts
are likely to be right
so i don't know let's pick an area so i
have pretty good instincts about
debugging programs
a very similar domain very similar type
of thing is something like medical
diagnosis
which i sort of as a as a slight hobby
try to try to know something about but
the instincts and the intuition is a
little different there
you know sometimes uh you know sometimes
there are like
oh you know there's a question you know
is the simplest explanation likely
the right explanation sometimes that's
true sometimes it isn't true are these
different
you know symptoms that you see whether
it's in a program or whether it's a
medical diagnosis are they connected
uh of the same cause or are they
separate things you know
that that's a place where you sort of
gradually get more intuition
a better instinct about what's going on
and i think one of the challenges
is to know when you don't know um and to
know when you've got to the point where
yes
you know this is a domain in which i
kind of know what i'm doing to the point
where i can sort of trust the instinct
that i have where i can sort of
where the match that i'm making to the
the thing that i've seen before
is an accurate match rather than like uh
you know you see this and it isn't
really a match i mean you know what one
is dealing with this all the time
uh you know since i i as a day job run a
company
um the uh you know one is always dealing
with companies are native people
and one's always dealing with people and
what are people able to do what are they
not able to do
when somebody says oh this is really too
difficult for me what does that really
mean what is the what is one sort of
instinct about whether it's true or
whether the person is just a little bit
tentative and they you know they're not
really sure of themselves
and really if you just say look you
really can do it it'll work out just
fine
um and those are things where sort of
gradually over the years i've sort of
built up a certain degree of of of
intuition about what's going to happen
but you know if you if you confront me
with a situation that i haven't seen
before
of of some thing people are sort of
infinitely complicated and there are
there are always different kinds of
things that happen um and uh you know
something where i just haven't
seen that before i haven't seen that
particular kind of life situation
somebody is in
that particular kind of uh background
somebody has whatever else
uh then it's actually pretty difficult
and and the main thing to learn
is that when you don't know and uh and
then you have to kind of uh
it's it's sort of challenging to see
what you do in that case and you have to
kind of
uh kind of handle things in such a way
where you know you don't know
um and so you you have to kind of
proceed on that basis
anyway that's a little bit of a sort of
thoughts about um
the role of of um of instinct i think
another thing
is when somebody asked me about
something you know i spent a lot of my
my time we even live stream a bunch of
these things doing uh
a software design reviews and saying you
know how should this particular piece of
uh computational language be designed
things like that
one of the things that's interesting is
that i kind of at this point i think
know myself well enough to know
when somebody asks me a question i'm
going to think about it a bit
i'm going to be able to come up with
some answers and there's this kind of
curve
of if i got a particular question if i
got something reasonable to say in five
minutes
that's good if you give me another hour
i'm not going to have much more to say
and there are other questions where you
know i know it's going to take me two
hours to really dig into that question
and be able to make an answer to it so
it's sort of an interesting thing what
is it
that one can given you know the
experience one has or whatever else
what is it where you might as well just
say this is what i know in five minutes
because that's going to be as good as
you'll get uh without
you know huge huge amounts of effort and
that's sort of the question of when
when has that particular question been
turned into one that you can sort of
answer by instinct
versus when is it a question where it
makes sense to kind of
work through all its details um to see
to see where you can get to
so that's some uh that's a
a few thoughts about that question all
right
oh gosh lotta lots of um
lots of different questions here um
oh my
well there's a question here from um um
so many different questions all right
let's try this one from a toure again
uh what is the financial market
okay let's see very different kind of
question um
and uh i guess there are a variety of
ways to to
try to answer that i mean the sort of in
in the simplest way that an economy can
work
people own things people want to
uh you know i own a sheep you own a dog
i want a dog and you want a sheep so
great let's exchange the dog for the
sheep
okay well what if we think those two
things aren't of exactly equal value
what if um a sheep is worth
you know one and a half dogs how does
that work
what do we do well we could start saying
well i've got two sheep one dog
etc etc etc etc etc but it gets pretty
complicated
and so it's very convenient to have some
medium something like money for example
where you can say well this sheep is
worth
i don't know what a sheep costs a
thousand dollars let's say i have no
idea if that's correct um
you know this it probably depends on the
part of the world you're in and and so
on but
but let's say this sheep costs maybe
it's much less than that i don't know
this sheep costs a thousand dollars this
dog uh
costs fifteen hundred dollars okay we've
got the sort of medium of exchange
that is just turn both of them into
money and we can kind of
uh we can kind of exchange the money so
so it's kind of the
the the notion is is there a way of kind
of
a associating having having some
some way of exchanging things that is
more efficient than just saying one of
this for one of that
and so on and that's that's why it's
convenient to have things like money
well now of course the question is well
these things you know how do we decide
how much the sheep is worth how much do
we decide
how much that dog is worth well the um
uh in the end in a sense that the price
of something
is sort of defined by well it's how much
people will pay for it
well that's again a bit complicated
because it's like how do you know how
much people will pay for it it could be
that everybody
who is uh you know who lives on your
block
would only pay this amount for it but
there's somebody who lives in the next
city
who would pay twice as much for it how
do you resolve that how do you
how do you manage to figure out sort of
how much things are worth
in a in a market that is big enough that
you can sort of get
the value that anybody would pay for it
now of course it's even more complicated
because let's say
you're buying a thing but the thing is
uh you know you buy a a
a pile of bricks well you know if the
bricks are right there at your
construction site they're worth a
certain amount to you
if the bricks are on the other side of
the world it's going to cost you a lot
to ship the bricks to your construction
site so that you can use them so the
the value may depend on things that are
different from just what the thing is it
may depend on like where it is or
or other kinds of conditions about it or
somebody might say
you can only use these bricks to build
this kind of house
well if that's kind of house you're
building that's worth something if it's
a different kind of house
then then it's not worth anything to you
so the question really is how do you
make it efficient
for people to to be able to to sort of
uh buy things and to set the prices for
those things how does that all work
well this is something i suppose it
originated i'm sure it had
origins and even antiquity but but
certainly by the 1600s
there was starting to be pretty
organized markets where people would
uh would basically say i've got this
thing how much do people will people pay
for it now there were some markets that
got very out of control
uh famously the the um market for tulip
bulbs in the netherlands was a great
example of this
um uh where there were these some uh
people
it was like people would say i've got
this great tulip bulb
how much will somebody pay for it and
some people said that's a really really
cool kind of tulip balm it's going to
make this amazing black tulip or
whatever else
you know i'll pay this amount for it and
then somebody else will say no no i'll
pay more for it
and so it was kind of an auction where
people would say i'll pay more i'll pay
more i'll pay more i'll pay more
and eventually people are paying absurd
amounts of money for these things
that were probably not really in line
with what one would really consider
the value of the thing to be but kind of
this idea
that you'll have a market where people
will say i'll pay this i'll pay that
you can kind of have an auction where
for example in the simplest form of
auction
just the person who bids the most before
the auction is over
uh gets to buy the thing there are more
elaborate forms of auction
uh where it's kind of the um uh you know
we have different kinds of bids and the
and the second highest bidder is the one
who wins or the
you know all kinds of other all kinds of
other elaborate schemes
which try to encourage people to um uh
to have um
to sort of bid the most um for for the
particular thing
for example in in selling ads on the web
they're all kinds of elaborate bidding
schemes
even more elaborate are the schemes used
to sell off um
pieces of radio spectrum by by countries
and things like that
um they're very elaborate kind of and
that sometimes there are more
complicated constraints there it's more
valuable
to own neighboring things and and so on
and so on and so on
but any case so the sort of the idea of
a um a financial market in a sense a
market
is to uh is to have um
uh is to say um you know there's this
thing um
and to let people who want to buy that
thing uh sort of
figure out uh be able to bid against
each other to see how much
that is what what the sort of true price
of how much somebody will pay
is so a lot of the markets in
um uh uh that people uh pay
most attention to these days are markets
sometimes for commodities
uh for things like i'm gonna buy a big
lump of copper or i'm gonna buy a bunch
of uh
uh one of the favorite ones is pork
bellies which is you know some
some kind of meat um and um the uh
or the you know markets for the
commodities like grain and so on
um these are that's one type of thing
where people are
are and usually what happens is it gets
very elaborate because
you might say well i'm just going to buy
you know
five tons of of of copper or something
but then you say well actually i just
want to say
that if i wanted to buy five tons of
copper
at uh you know three weeks from now
then i want to be able to get it for
this amount of money i want an option to
be able to buy that amount of copper for
this
at this time and then somebody can make
a
can sell you that option where they
ultimately somebody will be buying that
that
piece of you know that that pile of
copper but somebody will sell you the
option to be able to do that and they
will sort of arrange
that that's possible if and and you can
kind of sell this derivative on what
the underlying transaction is and things
get very elaborate in the last probably
20 or 30 years
there's been sort of a a bigger and
bigger tower of selling sort of options
to options and so on
um wireless headset is dying
ah okay let me just um switch to
something different here
um let me see how to do this
um
for some reason i am not seeing the
usual thing that i would expect to see
here
all right let's try that can you hear me
again
yes yes okay great
all right where was i we were talking
about um
uh we're talking about
financial markets and um uh and so on
um oh so many questions here um
uh okay um
so so one one sort of big
chunk of sort of markets are commodities
markets where
you're dealing with buying actual stuff
like grain
or or whatever else or copper or
whatever
um the um another
another type of market are stock markets
um and kind of the idea there is um
let's see how deep i want to get into
this but but um um
so you know companies um
that make things whether it's you know
apple making computers or whether it's
some
uh a phone company selling you phone
service so whether it's some
uh other kinds of things companies um
uh there's a question of who owns those
companies
um and uh there are basically two big
categories of companies private
companies and public companies the lines
are getting a little blurred these days
but a private company is ultimately
owned
uh just by private people so for example
my company
is very it's you know i own most of it
um
and uh it's a it's a it's a company
where um
in in the end if the company does well
uh you know i make money if the company
doesn't do well i don't make money it's
kind of for some simple setup
the um there's another scheme which
involves the public owning companies so
the idea is
that uh you can buy a small percentage
of some company let's say the company is
i don't know apple microsoft whatever
uh the um you can buy a share of this
company that means that you are
you have a piece of paper that says that
you own
a a tiny fraction of that company and
you can and that that the question is
how much is it worth how much is that
tiny fraction of the company worth
well that depends on how much the whole
company is worth and
again fundamentally what determines how
much it's worth
is how much people are prepared to pay
for it um and so
what happens is there are there are
financial markets the stock market
things like the new york stock exchange
the nasdaq
um uh exchange exchange
london stock exchange all kinds of other
stock exchanges
um where what's happening is people are
buying and selling
these shares of companies these tiny
tiny fractions of
of companies and people will sometimes
say oh they say that company is really
going to do well in the future
it's worth a lot more than i thought it
was worth i'm going to pay more for it
and so the price of that stock will go
up
or oh that company you know it had it
claimed that it had this great drug that
was going to cure everything and it
didn't
oh that company isn't really worth as
much as we thought the the price of the
stock will go down and so on
um and uh you know there's a question of
how what is ultimately
the value of a company and again
ultimately the value is what people are
prepared to pay for it
so a company that is a public company
where its shares are traded in a stock
exchange
basically the in a first approximation
the value is just what people are
prepared to pay for those shares
now sometimes if one company buys
another company if one company buys the
whole of another company
then that provides a different way of
figuring out the value because it's like
that company is worth five billion
dollars okay it's worth five billion
dollars because somebody just bought it
for five billion dollars
not because people in the public kind of
said oh the shares in this company
that little fraction of the company is
such that it would the whole thing will
be worth five billion dollars
it's a slightly different way of
estimating it now one of the things
that's a long-term
question in sort of the theory of of
economics and
stock markets and so on is is there is
there sort of a ground
truth is there an ultimate way of
knowing how much something like a
company is worth
and so one one of the things that
happens is so how does a company how
does
how does sort of the financial setup of
a company work
well a company let's say a company is
selling things
selling bricks selling computers
whatever else
it the company brings in a certain
amount of revenue
it brings in people pay a certain amount
of money let's say every year
they pay a hundred million dollars for
for the stuff the company sells
okay well but let's say the stuff the
company is selling is computers
the computers cost the company something
to make
and so the company the the the company
might get 100 million dollars
but much of that money was just paid out
to
the people who made the components of
the computers the people who assembled
the computers
the employees of the company who helped
develop the computer sell the computer
et cetera et cetera et cetera so the
revenue the original
sort of how much was paid by by outside
people paying money into the company for
for their goods is you subtract you have
to subtract from that what the
costs of the company were and so then
the
net the the revenue minus the costs
is usually called in at least an
american accounting net income
um and again some details here about
taxes and things like that but let's
ignore those
the the um uh the um the the net
income uh is kind of the
the um the the money the company sort of
makes
in some sense there's money that comes
into the company but the company's just
going to have to pay it out again
and there's money that the company makes
as profit
money that the company create made that
it didn't it didn't have to pay out
and so what companies that uh uh
some companies oh i don't know companies
that like utility companies electrical
companies things like that companies
that
that their companies that sort of have
set themselves up to the point where
they are reliably going to make
a profit just because they know they pay
a certain amount out for the
electrical wires or whatever you know
but
and the people are going to pay a
certain amount for the electricity they
use
so the company is basically always going
to make a profit and then
the way that that then works is that the
company will then pay out dividends
to the shareholders of the company so
the people if you
own .001 of that company
then you will get if it decides that
from those profits it's going to
distribute
you know i don't know 50 million dollars
um of those profits in a particular year
then you will get for your point
whatever i said zero zero one percent
share
you will get some number of dollars just
handed to you as cash so to speak
um and that's so that's a mechanism by
which companies uh bring back
money to their shareholders is by paying
dividends
so one theory would be oh the value of a
company
is just the well sort of discounted
future value
uh discounted that is the equivalent of
just imagine all those dividends you
would get maybe that's 50 years from now
you would get those dividends this
company
will have made so much money that it
will be paying out
uh paying out cash as dividends just
imagine all that money you would get
many many years from now um and um
the um and and then
come back and say well if i was going to
get that money in 50 years
that's worth a certain amount now
because i could have
been i could borrow money and i i have
to explain them
notion of present value which is um
let's let's say that
that having money in the future versus
having money now you can kind of
exchange those two things by thinking
about borrowing money for a certain
amount of time
and then paying it back um but so so one
theory is the value of the company is
some kind of discounted future
uh dividends uh that theory is usually
not correct
for for if you look historically at the
stock market so
so in the end the theory boils down to
the price of the
i mean that would be nice if there was
sort of a ground truth value where you
could say
this is how much things are worth in the
stock market but but it isn't really the
way it works
and and usually there's a um one of the
things that happens is
the price of some company will kind of
fluctuate around sometimes the company
will think you know people think the
company's going to do great the price
goes up
people think companies can do crummy the
company price goes down et cetera et
cetera et cetera there's a certain
volatility the price is jumping up and
down all the time
um there's a certain volatility to the
price and
one of the sort of theories of how the
market works
is that if you are prepared to invest in
something
with sort of higher volatility the
average return the average rate at which
the price will go up
will be higher if there's higher
volatility or more to the point what
what ends up happening is people build
these portfolios where you have all
these different companies whose values
are jumping up and down
but you say if you average all of those
or you make the total of all of those
then you can end up with a stable thing
which gets you better results
than if you were just investing in a
single company
that doesn't have the same kind of
fluctuation or a single thing doesn't
have the same
fluctuation there's hugely more to say
about this
i'm happy to talk about it some more
some other time and can talk a little
bit about
the interaction between um maybe some
other time the interaction between kind
of
science and mathematics and thinking
about financial markets but that's at
least a
a first first cut of that
okay um let's take a look here
um
oh my gosh
okay somebody is saying currently a
sheep costs a hundred pounds ahead in
the uk all right
so uh um that's about
what is it these days gosh i don't even
know the conversion rate 150
or something in the us um
okay let's see um
uh it's a question here
that's uh
el joker is asking
a um a question commenting that jack
dorsey
has endorsed my idea of algorithms for
ranking well i'll explain what the idea
is but then it's asking will i be an
advisor for the implementation of this
oh it's a that's a that's a complicated
question but but let me let me
talk about the the underlying part of
that question
um so when we use the web
the internet lots of services we use
have one thing in common they're they're
all
involved with taking content that people
have put on the web in some way
put on the internet in some way and
ranking which content we should actually
see
so when we use a search engine and we
search for how much is a sheep cost or
something
um there's a question of of all the
possible things that might be responsive
of all the possible web pages
that might say something about how much
a sheep costs um
you know which one will we will be put
on top so that's one example of kind of
automatic content selection that goes on
on the internet
another example is if you use something
like facebook and you have a news feed
there's a question of you know which
pieces of news do you get news about
people who are close friends of yours do
you get news that's about the world in
general
you know how do you rank what kinds of
things you should see
and on twitter for example twitter is
all about these little bursts of uh you
know tweets
um and it's a question of well which
tweets should you see
which tweets are the ones that um uh
you um which tweets are going to be best
for you to see
it's a little bit of a question at best
for who but um so one of the things
that's developed
now is this very complicated and rather
ugly situation
of like who decides which tweets you're
going to see
who decides which things you're going to
see well in actuality
it's the companies that build the
technology who decide
and there's a question of what should
the basis for that decision be
so in a sense for a company if they can
show you things
that cause you to for example read more
tweets
spend more time on facebook whatever
else it's good for the company
it would be foolish and irresponsible to
the
shareholders of the company and so on to
not optimize things so that
the company did the best it can from
uh getting people to use its service so
from that point of view the best thing
to do
is to give you is to feed you content
that is might not be the most relevant
from some abstract intellectual point of
view
but is the thing that is most likely to
keep you
continuing to read content on that
particular service
now one bad thing that happens is that
that sometimes the it's the nature of
people
that you know more people will sort of
buy a newspaper that has a shocking
headline
than buy a newspaper that just says oh
nothing really happened today
so that tends to make it
be the case that if you want to have
content that
causes you to that causes people to to
say i'm going to read more i'm going to
read more
it's going to end up being the more
shocking the more surprising content
often
and that tends to mean that that the
content gets sort of more and more
extreme that's that's one of the things
that happens and
and you might very well say well that's
not really great that people are just
shown
all the shocking content not even
showing all the stuff that might be
really interesting it might make them
feel very happy and etc etc etc
they're showing all this shocking stuff
because it makes them want to read more
and more and more but
you know if you're a company that's
trying to set this up i suppose it's
unsurprising
that at least in the short term the
optimal strategy is just get people to
read more
put more stuff out there that gets
people to read more that's one dynamic
another dynamic is if you're a company
the company has employees
the employees have opinions the um uh
the employees may say oh i like this
area of politics i don't like this area
of politics i like this kind of thing i
don't like that kind of thing
and it's sort of a natural human thing
that they'll say well look
you know if i don't like this then
yeah probably other people aren't gonna
like it too or maybe i just don't want
people to see this
so let me let me make sure that my
platform my
my uh my system doesn't
uh doesn't um uh doesn't put out
those um uh those things let's say let's
just say
i'm just not gonna put out you know if
there's some
piece of i don't know politics or
whatever else i don't agree with let me
just not put it out
on my particular uh system okay so
that's a that's another dynamic and
other people say no no you can't do that
well you can say look we're the company
we run the service if you don't want to
use the service
don't use the service but nevertheless
people can say it's not doing good
things for society
to sort of break things up to the point
where you're saying oh nobody can see
that
it's it feels very much like it goes
against principles in the u.s like
things like free speech
and so on that say well you should be
able to at least
say whatever you want um people might
not agree with you
people might say i if if you put that
stuff out
you know if you make a newspaper or
something and you're always running
headlines that
people don't agree with then maybe the
people who don't agree with them are
going to stop buying your newspaper
and that's sort of a dynamic that that
can happen
well so so the issue is
uh well so one of the questions is
uh for example i mean there are many
layers of issue here but but
um another kind of issue is if you are
a company that's doing automated content
selection from the internet
yes you're doing search engine you're
doing social media you're doing micro
blogging whatever
you're you're um you know you're a
company that's just basically taking
content that
people are putting out there and you're
just selecting it for other people to
read
what responsibility do you have about
what that content is
and uh for example if somebody says
somebody
you know took my book
and they put it out on they they posted
it
uh on on their social media thing and
they they
violated my copyright they stole that
thing from me
uh what to what extent can you
tell the company that is running the
social media platform
oh no take it down you know that's
that's illegal content take it down
well in the us there were a bunch of
laws that were passed that had to do
with those kinds of things one of the
issues is
if you're dealing with billions of
pieces of content it's really difficult
to know oh what what's not okay what's
okay and so on it's very difficult to
to pass that out and so they're things
like the digital millennium
copyright act that basically says if
it's if it's up there and somebody says
look it's my copyright you've got to
take it down
then there's a procedure for getting it
taken down and so on there's another one
of these which is um
uh there's a much more controversial
thing the communications decency act i
guess
and i should if i really knew my stuff i
would be able to quote you what section
it was but i
i can't um but there's a there's the
question
of if you are a
uh an automated content selection
business if you're
uh something that's putting content on
the internet but it isn't originally
your content you didn't make it up
you just somebody put it there you chose
it for other people and so on
or you just put it out there what
responsibility do you have
for for deciding what's out there
well one position you might take is
that you're just a sort of common
carrier of content
that basically whatever people put out
there you're gonna let it be out there
and it's up to other it's up to the
people who read it do they read it do
they not read it do they say it's stupid
do they attack it
it's up to them and that's that's the
way that a number of services in the
past
work like for example i don't know the
postal service
you can send any letter the phone system
you can make any phone call
it's you know there are limitations
about you know their you can be attacked
because you made a phone call that was
illegal in some way
but the phone company is not going to be
the one that says
oh no we don't like this phone call you
can't make it
so the question then is you can kind of
be a
common carrier of content where it's
just like anything goes you just put it
out there
in a sense the web is pretty much that
way anybody can put up a website
and it's just it is there um and
um but in these uh companies that do
automated content selection
there's the question of should they work
that way should they be just sort of
common carriers where they put anything
out there
of course if you're a common carrier
you're not really responsible for what
you put out there
because it's like we're just putting
everything out there so it's not not our
responsibility
well there's a concern that all kinds of
all kinds of terrible content
might be put out there that that is
considered for example just outright
illegal in the us and most other
countries
um and so there was this uh law that was
put in place that said
uh you know okay those things you can
take down
if somebody puts up something
sufficiently something that's just plain
illegal
you can take it down but in the
particular law that was written there's
a long
sentence and it goes through you can
take down this or that or the other
thing
um or content that says or
content that can be taken down is this
this or this or
otherwise objectionable and i think it's
those three words that have caused more
trouble than anything else in this whole
discussion
because it's like what's objectionable
objectionable to who
for what purpose so that has been
interpreted as meaning
well you know if you're operating one of
these services
you just if you don't like it you can
take it down
it's not the sort of common carrier
theory where it's just like anything
goes and it's up to the readers to
decide what to do with it
or up to you know governments to decide
what's illegal and what's not and so on
so okay so that that sort of created
this weird situation where
where among other things that's that's i
mean the
both the the structure of these
platforms and
the um and that particular feature has
created this situation in which
there's sort of the the companies like a
twitter for example
uh sort of thinks to themselves well yes
we should control a bit what content we
have we can't control all of it
we sort of could control it a bit and
what are our forces in controlling it
well there's
you know get more people to use twitter
that's one thing there's our employees
feel this way or that way that's another
thing
there's you know projection for what do
we think is good for the world
that's a hard thing to figure out et
cetera et cetera et cetera so that's
that's kind of the environment
and and in practice this has led to all
kinds of things that people get very
upset about
uh i personally think some of these
things uh well i
if i were running these companies i
would do it differently but
um um you know i think that the the
issue is
um in uh sort of
in the end who decides what you're going
to see on twitter
is it twitter who decides is it or is it
somehow you who decide or how does that
really work
um you know by the way i might say that
one feature of the web
is that in some sense nobody owns the
web the web is this very complicated
patchwork of all these different
uh companies that provide uh you know
the com
the communications links and all the
companies that provide sort of web
hosting so
it's a big patchwork and so it's not one
of these things where you can say
oh can you be on the web or not on the
web it's
it's not really it's sort of anybody can
put up a website now it's a little bit
more complicated because to have your
website be found
you have to be in dns servers et cetera
so
there are some slight constraints but
but in a first approximation it's kind
of like a common thing anybody can put
put stuff out there on the web
whereas with something like twitter you
know twitter invested in building the
infrastructure that lets you read all
those tweets and so on
and it owns that infrastructure and you
might say it's it's only fair that it
can decide what should be on there and
what shouldn't be on there okay
but but nevertheless that puts a twitter
for example
in this ultimately i think very awkward
position because it's like well what
should be there and what shouldn't be
there
some people would say that oh my gosh
you know
you shouldn't show people pictures of
some horrible thing
you shouldn't uh tell people oh there's
this thing in the world that's
tremendous
you know tremendously bad you know go do
something about it you shouldn't tell
people
oh we're going to have this giant riot
and this place go be there
these kinds of things that there are
things that it's sort of bad to tell
people
and the question is then how do you
decide what's bad
and what's not bad and how do you who
decides what's bad and what's not bad
it's very difficult you end up being in
a situation if you're
if you decide i'm the company i'm in
charge of the service
you have to be sort of the moral arbiter
of the world
is this good is this bad is this not
good it's not et cetera et cetera et
cetera
now that's ultimately pretty much
impossible
because you know there are different
people different cultures different
countries different
uh uh belief systems and so on that
people have and
people just don't agree on what's good
what's not good
you know there are countries where
there'll be a particular type of animal
that uh is eaten as food in another
country that type of animal will be kept
as a nice pet
if you you know the the the beliefs
about what to do
are completely different in those two
different countries and you know
there'll be other
all kinds of other things which you know
you can slice it up in all kinds of ways
about what um uh you know how to decide
what's
you know what for somebody as good as
for somebody else is bad et cetera et
cetera et cetera
and for somebody it's like oh my gosh i
don't want to see that and somebody else
is like oh yeah no problem you know we
do that all the time type thing
um so how do you decide
so as i say that the situation right now
is that it's a centralized decision
there are a small number of companies
that are basically
choosing what people should see and
uh needless to say not everybody likes
that um i think if
as i said i was running one of those
companies it's a very difficult
situation because
you're kind of being asked make a moral
decision for the world
make a decision you know should you
support if somebody is is you know
pushing to overthrow the government of
country x
should you say yeah it's okay well no no
no don't do that
you know it's a hard decision to make um
and it's a it's a posit
it's a decision that puts you in a
position that
where you're sort of guaranteed that
some fraction of people are going to
hate you for whatever you do
okay so what can you do about that well
so happened i don't know when was it a
year and a year and a bit ago um i
happened to
um end up uh agreeing to give some
testimony for a
committee in the u.s senate about um
about these kinds of questions um and so
the question was so what can be done
about this um
you know what how can one deal with i
think i coined the name
automated content selection businesses
because i didn't really know a
collective name
for um for these types of types of
businesses and types of companies
but so so i am uh so i was
like one of the possible ideas was well
the systems that do the choosing of what
content you'll see
those are essentially artificial
intelligence ai systems they're big
pieces of code they involve all kinds of
rules and
this is and that's and they're just big
big pieces of code
so one idea was let's just get all these
companies
to be able to show those pieces of to be
forced
to show some government agency those
pieces of code
so we can check that those pieces of
code don't do anything bad
okay so the problem with that is if you
have a complicated piece of code and
particularly one that's using modern ai
techniques
it's if you ask the question what does
this code do
the answer is that's very complicated if
you say will this code ever do anything
bad
it's an unanswerable question because it
depends what you mean by bad you have to
define what you mean by bad
and even if you define what you mean by
bad it's kind of a question an issue of
sort of theoretical computer science
that it's arbitrarily difficult to
figure out will this particular piece of
code ever
you know hit that particular point which
you consider bad or not
it's it's something which is sort of
theoretically unanswerable
there's this phenomenon i call
computational irreducibility that kind
of
shows one that this is not a not it's
not a realistic thing to try to do
now it could be the case that somebody
did something very shocking and i'm
afraid i
i do know that that this does happen
that somebody will just put into the
code
something that says if it's this person
don't show their results and um the uh
uh you know so in other words there are
things where if you looked at the code
you could say hey that's something you
probably shouldn't have done
but for the vast the vast majority of
what's happening
it's a complicated algorithm it's been
optimized in certain ways
it's it's very hard to know definitively
is it good or bad in some definition of
good or bad
so i was uh was sort of getting ready to
to give that kind of testimony about
about why that particular approach
wasn't going to work
i was a little bit embarrassed that i
was just coming and i'm basically going
to say look i uh
main thing i can tell you is that what
you're thinking of doing isn't going to
work
so i thought i'd better actually come up
with some some idea
for what one could do that would
actually work and i realized that
there's actually a really obvious idea
and and the obvious idea is this it's a
question of
of uh why does it have to be the case
that the company that provides all of
the infrastructure that routes all those
tweets
that attaches ads to tweets that puts
you know that that
uh crawls the web that does this does
that why does
that same company why does that why does
it have to be the case
that it picks the final ranking of
content
for any particular user why not have the
possibility of
other companies be able to do that well
you might say the best thing to do will
be for
a user to be able to do that for
somebody to just say i like this content
i don't like this content et cetera et
cetera
the problem is it's very difficult to
write something like a search engine or
a ranking algorithm for a search engine
it's very difficult to write a ranking
algorithm for a news feed it's not
something
everybody's going to want to do for
themselves but it's something where
you can effectively uh and it's also
something where
the organization has the most
information about how people actually
pick what they like and so on
has a tremendous advantage in doing a
good job at
um at ranking things correctly so the
question is can you take advantage
of the fact that there's sort of this
collective benefit to everything being
together
while still having it be the case that
in some sense people can pick for
themselves how they want things ranked
now the fact is you have to realize that
picking for themselves is not going to
be realistic in the near at least in the
near future
one day maybe there'll be sufficient
level of computational literacy
in the world that people will be able to
kind of write little specifications in
computational language
that say oh i don't want to see this i
do want to see that and so on but for
the time being that's that's pretty much
unrealistic
so then the question is how do you deal
with that well you have to have kind of
a proxy
for what the person's preferences are
and and sort of
the the obvious thing to do is to make
use of
all those kind of existing kind of
organizations brands
you know whatever it is cultural
organizations uh
you know individual people with
particular brands
you know companies that put out some
particular kind of thing
you know to to make use of that existing
kind of uh
value system information that comes from
oh i like this company i like this
particular
celebrity i like this particular
organization etc etc etc
to make use of the fact that people
already know those preferences that they
have
and then say can you capture the values
of one of those organizations
in some kind of custom-made ai that then
that user can say oh i want to pick the
one
that is from company x or from celebrity
y
whatever else that that captures to the
best of the ability of the of the
creators of the thing
that captures the preferences of company
x you know
organization y whatever else and then
say well i'm going to
look at my twitter feed and i'm going to
look at it
as as ranked using the values
of such and such an organization and so
then the idea is
and sort of there's a it's complicated
because you want to get the advantage
of kind of the collective advantage of
knowing more about all the users
uh versus not providing not sort of
breaking the privacy of the users as you
give
sort of the as you let a third party
organization uh kind of insert things
anyway i
i you know my main sort of
pseudo-technical achievement there
was uh both knowing a certain amount
about how these companies work and and
and after after that that that uh
hearing actually talking to these
leadership of these companies about sort
of how you actually do that plumbing
um of uh of of of actually inserting
this kind of um uh
you know inserting the value system in
such a way that
you can um uh you can let people kind of
pick
what value system they want to use for
the content that they're going to get
so that's kind of the idea and in a
sense i see that as being a way out of
what is otherwise a very difficult
situation for a company that is
you know it depends what business you
think you're in i mean if you think
you're in the business of
of kind of you know turning the world in
a certain direction that's one thing but
the
the history of of organizations that try
and turn the world in a certain
direction
is sort of the history of governments
and countries and things like that and
it's a history that uh
uh realistically you know if if one
knows the course of history
it um it is not uh you know you never
get to be
the the the thing that always does that
perfectly forever there'll be some group
that doesn't like it and you
you end up in worst case you know you
end up in some big war and
et cetera et cetera et cetera it's it's
not a does not usually end well
um and so so i think that the um
uh uh sort of the alternative is it's
just
you know you're operating one of these
businesses that has built this big
platform
for uh for distributing content it's
just you're just dealing with a platform
you're just dealing with things like how
the advertisers interact with that
platform
etc etc etc and the final choice of what
any particular user sees
is something where they're picking sort
of the value system that they want to
use for that content
and so so that's that's kind of the idea
and
i have to say i was kind of more
enthusiastic about some
um uh kind of implementing this idea
because i think it's an interesting
interesting story of the use of ai and
the way that that we understand ai
and so on i thought it was
intellectually pretty interesting
um and uh sort of getting ready to do
things with that actually um
about a year ago a little bit more than
a year ago now um
and then then what happened uh uh for me
was that um
we made a lot of progress on this
physics project and i kind of turned my
attention to the physics project
then the other thing that happened was
kind of the the world of
of modern politics got sort of more and
more intense and
and divisive and it's like anything you
do in this area
somebody's going to hate you for it and
and that's uh
um that's that's never a big incentive
to uh
uh for action so to speak um but it's
something where
i think the um uh the thing that um
uh that that is is interesting well i
mean a couple of things that
i i so far as i can see
this kind of idea that that um i've been
talking about is kind of the only way
out
i mean the other way out is that you
stop having just a few companies
that operate all these platforms the
problem with that is that many of these
things like a social network for example
there is considerable value to having
the thing be centralized because if you
like you're you know you want to connect
to the people on the social network you
don't want
25 different social networks and it's
like you know saying oh are you on
network a or b or c or d or whatever so
what
a couple of alternatives one alternative
is you say okay let there be
25 networks and define interoperability
standards where
you can say well you're on these
different networks and they have
different preferences
and then there's some sort of way of
having these networks interoperate
that's one possibility
i think that's fraught with difficulty
because i think that you end up
you know that interoperability standard
will end up being the lowest common
uh denominator of what everything does
and so you'll you'll sort of
lose the features that you might want to
have that way
um and you know the other alternative it
seems
to me is something like this kind of uh
thing that i've been talking about
um where you know there is a layer you
know you have one phone network so to
speak and all the phones connect to each
other
but there's sort of a layer on top of
that um that has to do
that didn't have to happen in the case
of the phone system that had to do with
how you decide what things people should
see and
i think that that um you know as a
practical matter there's a whole sort of
uh
industry that um uh needs to get created
around sort of being able to create
those kind of value capturing
ais where you go to company x
you know organization y whatever you say
to them
let's create this sort of value
capturing ai
that can then be plugged into a twitter
or a facebook or whatever
and that can give the users of that um
the uh
the ability to use your value system to
decide what content they want to see
um i think this is a i mean i i i mean
maybe i'm
maybe i i'm not able to see far enough
but
i think this is the only viable solution
that i can that i can see
and i and i have to say while i might
have thought you know this is not really
the kind of thing i i typically think
about
i noticed that um jack dorsey who's the
ceo
of twitter um who was doing some recent
hearing about um
uh about these things uh you know quoted
you know what i'd said about this stuff
and it wasn't like he quoted 20 other
things
it was like there's this proposal and
that's kind of
the story um and you know maybe there
are other proposals which i haven't
thought of
but this is the only one i can think of
that seems to get one out of the box
that one is currently in
um and uh i think it's a pretty decent
idea
um and i think it would uh uh you know
the the main sort of counter argument to
any idea like this
is oh my gosh if you get everybody the
choice of kind of what value system they
should use
to decide what content they see that
will mean that all these different
people will see different kinds of
things
well you know i have to say that's kind
of the way our species tends to work
you know people used to you know go to
different television channels they used
to
buy different newspapers they used to do
different things one could argue
that uh things have become more divided
now than they have been in the past i
don't really know that for sure i think
it doesn't help that that kind of
individually targeted advertising has
now come to areas like politics
and that wasn't really there before so
you can kind of you know you can kind of
target one group of people and say
this is the way the world really is and
we can prove it with advertising so to
speak
and then a different group sees
completely different advertising
and and may have a completely different
view of how the world works
um and that's that's a difficult thing
and so maybe that's made things
sort of more divisive now than they have
been in the past but you know
in from my point of view i i like to
think i i don't know how true it is but
i like to think that i'm sort of
interested in everything and we'll
listen to every point of view
um and uh i'm not sure that everybody
takes that same
viewpoint um i think it's i mean i find
it interesting to listen to all points
of view i don't necessarily agree with
them all
um sometimes i change my mind um and uh
you know that that uh
i suppose about some kinds of things
maybe i it's
unrealistic that i would change my mind
but others uh you know i
i might change my mind and one might
think gosh wouldn't it be nice for
everybody to
be exposed to as much information as
possible so they could make up their own
mind now
at some level that's unrealistic because
there's just a lot of information in the
world so you can't
you can't tell everybody everything you
have to do some level of ranking
um and then the question is then people
will say well just show them the right
information
just tell them the right things to do
just tell them you know
the right uh you know whatever well
that's great you know you can talk to
people who say just tell them the right
things
well the problem is you talk to one
person who says just tell them the right
things they'll say
you say well what are the right things
well they're this this this and this
you to talk to somebody else and they'll
be passionately saying just tell them
the right things
and they'll be a completely different
set of things in other words not too
surprisingly
people don't agree about everything and
people might say
oh you know group x let's pick
one near to my heart the scientists
let's say the scientists know best
let's pick what they say well you know
it doesn't always work out that well you
know i would say that that perhaps
because that group is
is uh kind of near to me i think i can
say that you know a lot of science makes
a lot of sense
not everything every scientist says
makes sense
sometimes people sort of assume that
science can go much further
than it actually can and make claims
that are like
we've proved it with science it's not
really true
turns out you know we proved it with
science but in another 10 years
it's like well actually the science has
now proved that it's complete nonsense
so you know it's it's um uh the standard
of
and there isn't really a gold standard
in science it's one of the interesting
things about science
is in kind of very formal areas like
mathematics
you can have a real sense of this is
true
you make certain assumptions you can
define what the assumptions are
you can say this is simply true we
followed the steps of the proof
and we know it's true in any area that
involves the real world
you can't really do that well at least
you haven't been able to do that
in other words people say well it's just
true that
thing x about biology about physics
whatever else well you can't know that
for sure because you don't know what
sort of the axioms of those things are
you might think you know what what are
the important things that contribute
you might think you know such and such a
thing about some virus or
such and such a thing about some other
thing but actually there might be some
effect you just didn't think of
that might change your conclusions it's
not like kind of mathematics where you
where you at least imagine you start
from from a particular very particular
set of axioms or
like when you deal with computers and
programs and so on
you are the program says what the
program says and the program does what
the program does
and there's not there's no kind of
wiggle room but in doing
science natural science there always is
there's always oh we didn't think of
that effect
now there's perhaps one exception which
is insofar as we've been successful
at actually figuring out the fundamental
theory of physics um
we we may have bedrock so to speak on
which we can base
kind of things we talk about about
physics we may be able to say
this is simply the way the world works
that is the you know we've turned sort
of physics into something more like
mathematics but most of the time in
practice
science doesn't work that way science
has certain assumptions it makes
sometimes the assumptions are implicit
sometimes they get overthrown for
example in our physics project
several assumptions that people have
made for basically the last hundred
years
about the way physics works it turns out
to wrong um they're not
what's interesting about the way in
which they're wrong is they're not kind
of
slam dunk wrong it's not like they say x
but
not x is true rather it's things like
because of the way they set up their way
of thinking about things
they came to a bunch of conclusions
implicitly that were not the case
they assumed that you know space and
time are the same kind of thing
because there's this mathematical
structure that makes them look the same
even though it's turned out now that
they really don't seem to be the same
kind of thing
they assume that i don't know you know
some
quantum amplitude is some complex number
because that's a convenient way to work
out the mathematics and they don't think
that actually that
that really should be broken into pieces
and so on so it's it's sometimes
it's it's not so much that science says
something that just turns out to be
plain not true but rather that the kind
of conceptual framework that the science
has developed
is one where one is is sort of is saying
this is the
this is the way to think about things
and we can think of nothing else
i mean this has happened for example in
biology in uh
in theory of evolution and natural
selection and so on
it's something very common there where
it's like that's the thing that's all
that's going on there's nothing more to
say about why biology is the way
biology is but actually there's plenty
more to to say
and and people when you kind of lock in
and you say
the only thing you can say the only
scientific thing to say is natural
selection
you kind of lock out a lot of other
things in that particular case about
sort of inevitable features of
biological organisms that are a result
of sort of the mechanics by which the
organisms grow
and things like this those are kind of
those are you know if you just say it's
natural selection nothing else
you don't get to talk about those kinds
of things all right that was a super
long answer
to a rather pragmatic and and direct
question um
uh i should probably wrap up real soon
here but but uh
so many interesting questions here um
let's see
ah
um
um
all right i gotta take a couple more
things here
okay so there's a question from the anos
janos
um since we collided particles and
accelerators
does a proton have a surface and what
does it look like
okay interesting question so
first thing to understand is protons are
very very small
and when we talk about what does
something look like
we're mostly talking about if we look at
it with our eyes for example
and we say let's you know we we look
with
you know light is coming from some
source of light and it's
it's bouncing off the object it's about
coming into our eye and we're
detecting it and it's like this thing
that i see before me
looks like this because the light that
falls on it
it has this effect on the light and then
then
i get to see the effect that it had on
the light so one of the issues is
that light is ultimately made of
uh the the light we see we can think of
in one way as a stream of photons
particles of light we can also think of
it as a sequence of waves that
kind of wiggle
in the case of visible light about a
trillion times a second
so the issue is the um what happens is
either the photons or these waves
whichever way we think about it
they have a certain that the the light
that we're dealing with
it has a certain size each of the little
particles of light in some sense has a
certain size
each of the um uh each of the sort of
pieces of the wave has a certain size
and if the thing we're trying to look at
is much smaller than that size we don't
get to use
those things to look at it in other
words because
it it's some uh the in order to just
have this thing and you know you're
you're kind of imagine um
what's a good example imagine that you
just have this kind of
uh this kind of uh yeah you have this
kind of probe a mechanical thing you're
kind of bashing it against something
you're trying to say what shape is this
thing okay your probe is a tiny little
needle
and it keeps on touching it in different
places okay we can figure out what shape
the thing is
but let's say the probe we have is this
great big paddle type thing
and it you know and it really can't tell
what the actual
shape of the thing is because that great
big paddle is is much too big
to to fit into all the holes and seal
little pieces
so that's the situation that we have
with protons with light
of the kind that we use to see things a
proton
is um about 100 000 times smaller than
kind of the size of the smallest sort of
piece of
uh you know so smallest photon roughly
that we use in in invisible light that
we see
so it doesn't really work to to think
about it that way so how can we figure
out
sort of what the the shape of a of a
proton is
well one good thing to do is to use
something that's even smaller than a
proton
to kind of look at a proton and
electrons
are and i'm kind of cheating a little
bit in the way i'm describing sizes of
particles and things i'm i'm
i'm uh the apologies to people who
understand quantum mechanics and so on
um the uh but um
uh an electron the the sort of the
smallest
electron in our theory of physics
is not a zero size thing but in the
usual theory of physics is zero size
it's certainly much smaller
than a proton well what happens is that
you can
if you if you have a an electron
that uh you kind of yeah
i'm going to have to explain something
else i thought i was going to be able to
avoid explaining this
okay so another thing
about physics is that the energy of a
particle
uh determines kind of how
how um uh to what extent
you can decide where the particle is so
so there's a
this idea the uncertainty principle in
quantum mechanics
that basically says you can't
expect both to know exactly where a
particle is
and to know how fast it's going you can
pick one or the other but you can't be
you can't kind of figure out both um
and uh there's all kinds of uh ways you
can kind of
understand why that might be the case um
but uh let's just assume it's the case
then what happens is if you have a
sufficiently high energy
particle um high enough momentum high
enough speed and so on
that allows you to much more localized
where the thing is
and so what ends up happening is if you
want to know what shape a proton is
what you do is you shoot very high
energy electrons at it
and you watch how those electrons
interact with the proton
and and sometimes the the um uh you
shoot that high energy
uh electron at a proton and the proton
will just go kaboom and it will sort of
break up into
lots of quarks and gluons and things and
they will reform into particles
and get a big mess but just sometimes
you'll just see the electron will just
sort of bounce off
the um the proton and and roughly uh you
can use well actually
the the you can use both cases but
basically the electron comes in
the electron bounces off in some
direction the kind of the the jargon
name for this is deep inelastic
scattering
um the uh uh what happens is uh when
the the electron has some uh
well actually that actually we don't
even need deep electric cluttering we
just need
we just need to look at what happens
when an electron a high energy electron
hits a proton how does the proton
deflect it
well imagine the proton was just a
sphere it would have certain
the chance if you have an electron that
hits it different places on the sphere
there will be a certain distribution of
of angles
that the electron would go to based on
hitting different parts of the sphere so
if the thing hits
just head on right at front of the
sphere it will bounce back the way it
came if it hit a little bit off center
will bounce up this way and so on
depending on the shape of that sphere
you would end up with a uh with a
different distribution a different
angular distribution
of electrons uh from from hitting the
proton
so the way you try and measure the shape
of a proton so to speak or even the size
of a proton
is by looking at that angular
distribution of electrons that come out
from scattering off of protons and
that's what's done in particle
accelerators was first done in the 1970s
and
1970s to try and sort of map out the
shape of a proton
okay so the um uh
in terms of what shape is it the the
main thing that people tried to map out
was how big is it
and sort of how fuzzy is it how much
does the uh does the
the sort of the density of of of stuff
inside it
vary with with position is it to have a
hard center and then it's sort of a lot
of fuzzy stuff outside or does it
does it come to sort of a hard edge or
what does that look like in the jargon
of particle physics those are called
structure functions
that are that define the um uh the sort
of the
the the structure of a proton
so so the answer is that what we know
pretty well
what the um what the kind of uh how much
stuff there is in a proton and it's
roughly a sort of bell curve type type
shape
of how much stuff there is as a function
of of distance from the center of the
proton
now what's its shape well in quantum
mechanics
there's another slightly complicated
thing essentially
a proton has to be perfectly spherical a
single proton has to be perfectly
spherical in some sense
um that's uh
yeah i'm okay roughly
the reason is that particles
spin around in some sense they have a
property called
spin which roughly means they're
spinning around
but it's a little bit more complicated
than that because actually spin
you might think if you just have a top
or something you can spin the top faster
you can spin the top slower
but particles don't work that way
they're just a fixed quantized set of
possible amounts of spin they can have
and so in the usual units this is done a
proton has a half unit of spin
and for example a photon has one unit of
spin um
and these these kind of the the the the
mechanism and quantum mechanics that
leads to the quantization of spin
also implies a certain kind of uh
of of of symmetry about
the the sort of the shape of the thing
so in some sense it is the case that
every proton is spherical
um in the sense that it is it um uh sort
of all the different
uh basically true i mean
if i'm really it's it's a little hard to
say what it means to be a certain shape
because we're we're um uh um
uh yeah i mean the tricky thing here is
uh you might say well if if that applies
to the shape of protons that they have
to always be spherical
what about the shape of a water molecule
the water molecule is also very small
it just has a you know it's it's got um
uh
but it's a definite shape and you know
once seen these pictures of you know the
water molecule is
is this kind of shape or even a nucleus
a big nucleus so you say that's a
that's a you know that nucleus is a
certain shape quite often
the way that works is it's a tricky
thing a proton
an individual proton just has a
particular spin
when you have a water molecule there is
a when the water molecule is kind of
sitting there
not rotating around it too has a
particular spin
but the typical water molecule that you
encounter in an actual experiment
is one that is essentially a a
combination
of the water molecule in its ground
state in its
and the water molecule in these various
states where the thing is kind of
spinning around this is a bit hard to
explain
but basically what happens is that
with something like a water molecule
there are many different possible states
and different
uh states of rotation so to speak and
the typical way that you look at a
watermelon you
measure the properties of a water
molecule they have a combination of
those things
that allow you to think of the water
molecule as this thing with a definite
shape
in the case of protons there is no sort
of
excited state of a proton that is like a
proton in a different rotational state
that just doesn't exist for a proton so
far as we know so far as we know
a proton is a proton you put energy into
a proton it either stays as a proton or
it breaks up into a bunch of other
particles
there's no sort of like excited version
of a proton and so
so that means that in in the theory of
quantum mechanics um it's kind of
necessarily the case that the proton
an individual proton has to be in a
sense perfectly spherical i'm i'm giving
a little bit of air quotes about the
perfectly spherical because in reality
because it has spin a half not spin zero
there's a little bit of complexity about
the way that works but but that's more
or less
how it works now there are more things
to say about what protons how protons
work because
protons aren't sort of the end of the
story about what's inside what because
inside protons there are quarks
there are primarily inside a proton
there are three quarks
two up quarks and a down quark there are
a bunch of gluons that are the particles
that um
get exchanged between quarks to kind of
bind them together to keep them inside
the proton
but actually in your average proton
there are also lots of quark antiquark
pairs that are forming and uh being
created and destroyed all the time
and so when you kind of look at what's
inside the proton there's a more
complicated set of things that are
inside a proton
and and those things in a those things
uh well it's kind of complicated but but
there is some sense in which some of
those things
have something which is not precisely a
spherical distribution
and that has to do with the the way that
the spinner half
that that spinner half of the proton
gets distributed
among the the things that are inside the
proton um
i think i i think i have to give a much
longer explanation that goes into a
bunch of
things about quantum field theory to
really really do a full
dive on on that particular issue but
that's at least a first approximation
um okay maybe one more here uh
okay i'm going to um maybe
two more about that um it's a question
here
from sal do you believe pursuing
computer science and
actuarial science is a good idea uh
context there's a first-year university
student taking both and considering
doing a degree in both
well i have to say i actually think that
is a good idea um
let me let me make a comment here you
know everybody says
computer computation is really important
they say
okay computation is important sort of
computational x
for all fields x is the thing that
seems to be important in those fields so
they say
i'm going to college i should study
computer science
well not really because you know
computer science there's a bunch of
methods
that have been taught in computer
science for a long time there's also
kind of the craft
of knowing how to program a computer
there's the
understanding of how to think about
things computationally but only some
pieces of that are taught in what's
usually called computer science
um what the thing that is most valuable
i think is how do you think
computationally
in in in about things in the world
and so really what you want to be doing
is computational x
for whatever exit is that you care about
so i think this
this idea that you pick the x and you
say well i'm going to use computation as
my methodology
that's much more sensible than just
saying i'm just going to study computer
science because
it's something to do with computation
because it really
that you know some of what's in computer
science is things about oh i don't know
how you write a compiler you know how
you structure a large program
if what you're trying to do is do
something like computational actuarial
science
it's pretty irrelevant those are not
things you need to know
uh the things you need to get an idea of
are how do you think about
uh actuarial science computationally and
and what do you
how do you how do you make progress in
that field computationally let me
explain
uh what is actuarial science for people
who don't know it's
it's insurance so what's the idea of
insurance it's like
okay i have a car or something
and um most of the time my car's to be
just fine
but there's a small chance that i'm in a
car accident and my car is damaged it's
going to cost
a thousand dollars to repair my car so
the um
the thing that one does is you pay a
certain amount of
you pay an insurance premium and let's
say you pay every month or every
six months or every year or whatever you
pay let's say you pay
um i don't know 50 or something um
of insurance every every um
three months or something and so you're
accumulating let's say that's 200
a year or something you're paying
insurance and but
you know the chances are that you'll
never
claim on that insurance nothing will go
wrong with your car you keep paying
the 200 to the insurance company every
year insurance company gets that 200
they never have to pay you anything but
there's a small chance
that you're in a car accident and
there's
you know you have to there's 5 000
of damage there's a hundred thousand
dollars dollars of
of liabilities whatever else it is you
know you have to pay a lot of money
the idea then is that the insurance
company uh will pay out that money
they'll pay that claim um and uh so so
the notion is
uh and then well then then the real
issue of actuarial science is
what premiums should you charge so that
the claims that get made get covered by
the premiums so there might be
a thousand people paying into their car
insurance
and only two of them will be in car
accidents that year
and so your the insurance company is
getting the premiums from all those
thousand people
but it's gonna have to pay out a certain
amount for those two that were in car
accidents
so the question is how do you set the
price for
um uh for that okay so
that's an interesting question and
people have been
you know selling insurance for at least
400 years
and there's been progressively better
knowledge about how to do it i mean
you know one of the things that that
happened i guess in the 1800s
was you know the idea of life insurance
can you insure somebody
against dying you know in the current
state of things everybody dies
so you might say that's a really
terrible insurance idea but then what
could develop was this idea well if you
die
earlier than you would be expected to
die then the insurance will pay out and
so on and so it becomes a quite
elaborate mathematical question
what's the right rate depending on the
rate at which people die and the rate at
which people are paying in their
insurance
and the and the fact that if the
insurance company has the money
five years earlier than they would
otherwise then it's worth more to them
and so on so it's a it's a kind of a
complicated balancing act
but the question in modern times is how
will things like insurance evolve
um in the future and one of the things
that's that's the case
now is normally i don't know if you buy
insurance for a car
uh you know i suppose some uh i'm
embarrassed to say i have not directly
done that for myself for a very long
time but but
um uh the um you know they'll they'll
ask some questions what kind of a car is
it how old is the car
what kind of a driver are you have you
had car accidents before
you know how old are you are you a a
crazy young
or a or a or a kind of uh a hopeless old
one or something or are you somewhere in
the middle
um i do remember when when i um yeah
anyway the the um um it's you know what
makes you a higher risk or a lower risk
i have to say i remember um i'm trying
to remember the details of this i don't
really remember them very well but i
remember
when i was first uh getting car
insurance in the u.s i
i happened to be i was probably well i
must have been
18 years old or something and um but but
maybe a little bit after that
i happened to get my phd in physics when
i was
was pretty young and i i remember this
conversation i'm trying to remember all
the details of it but
but um of of asking the you know the
insurance you know person they were
saying like
you know in order to set a premium
they're like how old are you
you know what's your occupation how much
do you drive every year blah blah blah
blah
and and i think one of the questions was
sort of what you know
what degree you know how much schooling
do you have or something like that and i
was like
well i happen to have a phd and it's
like and i i was saying well does that
mean my premium should go up or down
are people with phds at age 20 more or
less likely to be in car accidents
than people uh um who are otherwise just
20 years old
and without that particular
qualification um i i don't remember the
answer but um
and i'm sure it wasn't on the table so
to speak um but any case the the
the main challenge of of of sort of
actual earlier science is to figure out
what should the premiums be and the main
change in modern times is
we start to know a lot more information
in other words for example let's say you
are setting premiums for somebody
driving a car
there are insurance companies that will
give you a little box to put in your car
that measures uh how how you're driving
it measures for example how many
rapid decelerations do you have you know
how many oops i
didn't notice there was a red light you
know slam on the brake type thing
how many how many other things like that
do you have and
so by giving by using that kind of
information
it's possible to predict much more
accurately is this person likely to have
an accident or not
and so then there's sort of a
complicated dance of to what extent can
you use that information to set the
premium
in the medical case one of the ones
that's really awkward is if you know the
genetic
information for a person you might know
this person has genetics that make them
more likely to have this or that disease
so they're a worse insurance risk um and
so on but
in any case the main point is that that
there's just a lot more data in the
world
and so the question then is well how do
you
given that there's more data in the
world how do you use that data
to more accurately set insurance
premiums and then the question is
is it fair to people to use certain data
that you have about them for example
data that they have no control over
like what their genetics is or something
like that um to uh
to set these insurance premiums and
those are those are questions of about
laws and so on which
are different kinds of questions but but
the thing that's of relevance in sort of
actuarial science and so on is
how do you use this huge amount of data
to more accurately set those premiums
that's that's one sort of frontier
and that's really a question of how do
you think computationally about how the
world is represented
how do you get that sort of
computational representation of the
world
let me give you another example so
another thing that that might be
an insurance policy it might say you'll
get paid out
if you uh what's a good example
um i don't know you might uh you might
have weather insurance
you might say um
no let's do another type of insurance
you'll you'll you'll be paid out
you know you might be operating a a
company that rents
uh kayaks or something and you might buy
weather insurance
that says if it if it rains a lot then
i'm going to pay in this amount of money
so that in case i'm rained out on the
critical day
the insurance company will pay me back a
certain amount of money so somebody has
to price that insurance policy they have
to work out
what's the chance that it will actually
rain
and what how much should you ask in the
premium
if they're going to pay in every year
and only one year out of 20 or something
it's going to rain and you're going to
have to pay out again so so there are
things like that where you
where but but but i'm trying to think of
a case where where
it's a little bit more elaborate what
the conditions for the payout are
uh for example it might be something
where it says it pays out if it wasn't
if it wasn't your fault that this
happened and if this was the case and if
that was the case
and if it was you know publicly visible
that this happened blah blah blah blah
blah a bunch of conditions
so the question is what does the
contract look like that says
under what conditions the insurance
company will pay out well
what happens now is those contracts are
written just
in you know in as as documents where
they're written in english or whatever
else
but in the future one can imagine that
those documents become
computational contracts they become
things that are written in code so to
speak and that say
you know if this sort of source of data
that says
that there will be a um uh
um uh you know that it rains says it
rained
and this and that actually here's a
better example so let's say you're
buying insurance against
um you're buying fruit and you're buying
insurance against the fruit having
rotted
um you know while it was in transit to
you okay so then a question would be
is the fruit actually rotten and you
might say well an inspector will come
and look at the fruit and say whether
it's rotten
but in modern times one might say no
let's just get this machine learning
vision system
to look at the fruit and say whether the
machine learning system says it's rotten
or not
so you know that's a case where you
could feed that into one of these
computational contracts
and automatically get out the
information of
oh yes the insurance policy has to pay
out or no sorry we're not paying out for
that because
this condition wasn't was wasn't was was
violated or something
so so in other words it's a um actually
another example of that type of thing
would be um
uh not quite insurance policies but
something related is is like security
deposits for apartments or something
it'll be like
if you don't ruin this apartment then
you'll get your security deposit back
what does it mean to ruin the apartment
you know how many how many little you
know uh
holes can you make in the wall how many
little whatevers can you make well
those are things that you could imagine
you know machine vision system looks at
these things
and there's just a piece of code that
decides oh it's this amount that amount
and so on
so so one of the things is writing uh
insurance policies
where the condition for payout is a
computational contract
i suspect that that's the future and i
suspect that
there's a lot of very interesting things
that that have to be figured out about
what those computational contracts look
like
and how you essentially price insurance
against a computational contract
because once you have a computational
contract that says you know if it rained
if this happened if that happened you
can then start asking
given our model of the world about rain
or whatever else
what what is the chance that this
contract will be triggered
um or not and so that's that's another
sort of dynamic of of thinking about
some
so i mean these are kinds of ways in
which in which computational thinking
kind of i think will affect the future
of actuarial science
um i mean i kind of think that um uh
in a sense it's a little bit confusing
because
the more we know about the world the
less
in a sense it's a matter of i mean
actuarial science is really a matter of
if fate is does not smile on you and
something bad happens
then you've got insurance and the
insurance will pay out but if we know in
more detail
what is going to happen in the world it
becomes
less of a matter of fate less of a
matter of chance now i have to say that
my own
sort of scientific work on on things
like computational irreducibility
tells one you'll never be able to know
everything about what's going to happen
you know in fact in a sense i hadn't
really realized this before but in a
sense
computational irreducibility is the
proof that insurance will never be
worthless
that is that it will always be the case
that there are things where we can't
know what's going to happen
um and so it is for us something where
there's sort of a different chance of
different things happening
um anyway so so i think my my
statement would be that that um uh you
know it's always interesting i think
applying computation to new areas
actuarial science particularly in a time
when there's internet of things
sensors measuring things when they're
starting to be computational contracts
i actually think it's a pretty exciting
time to be um
uh to be involved with that i think also
there start to be better and better
models of the world also more and more
complicated things that one can write
insurance about
like one one category
fairly recent category cyber insurance
insurance against various kinds of
computer
attacks on your computer and so on and
that that that's also complicated
because it's unclear
what the kind of distribution of of
things that go wrong is it's unclear
what the model of that is
it's unclear what the um uh what kind of
counts as what kind of cyber attack and
so on
it's an area where there's but there's
all sorts of interesting issues that
that i think can be well represented
with things like computational contracts
um about about how that works so i would
i would say that's a
that's a good idea and um in uh
you know if you're interested in doing
things which are are sort of innovative
i think there's going to be a lot of
opportunity for innovation in the
boundary between actuarial science and
and computation perhaps more so than
than the most traditional computer
science
um but uh but certainly the kind of
methods of computation and thinking
about
machine learning and thinking about kind
of
thinking about computational language
and so on i i have to of course give a
pitch for
you know learn wolfram language because
it's kind of the thing that
gives one the best leg up on being able
to
uh sort of think computationally about
things
without necessarily having to know all
those details that will be taught in
sort of a
traditional computer science curriculum
okay um
oh my uh
let's see
um i think i was going to answer one
more
question here somebody comments
on my comment about phds professors are
absent-minded keep them off the road i
don't know whether that's supported by
the data
um oh boy there was a question here from
from my comment about about um uh about
protons how can protons be perfectly
spherical while being composed of three
quarks
that one is a oh boy that's a story of
quantum mechanics and it's a story of
how
uh quantum mechanics sort of says that
many different things happen
and we we make a particular measurement
and we say this particular thing
happened when we measured it
but really many different things are
happening and those many different
things
uh are distributing the quarks that make
up a proton
in sort of all possible ways and yes
when we make certain kinds of
measurements we will see this proton
appears to have it be in this
configuration
but another measurement even on the same
proton
would conclude something different this
is a little bit of a hard thing to
understand and maybe another time i can
talk about it
in more detail um
let's see um
now there's a question maybe i'll i'll
tackle this a different time
about the internet and versus worldwide
web maybe i'll just do one more thing
here
um
um
there's a question um
a person saying i went to a good
university studying mathematics not
computer science
um do i have any tips
on getting ahead of my class and into
research
uh saying i'm now this is where i
i i lose out from being too old but it
says
i'm a beast at programming which i don't
know whether that means good or bad
i'm going to assume good but i don't
actually know i i
this is the evolution of language that i
i'm afraid i'm not um
not as up to date as i should be um uh
but i'm going to assume that means
really good at programming so
i think uh the thing to understand about
math
is the methodology that's been used to
study mathematics
has for the most part not changed a lot
in a very very long time
i mean our own efforts over the last 30
something years with mathematica
um that has caused mathematicians
even the most pure mathematicians to use
computers at least a little bit
to do calculations and so on but usually
the way that the
people tend to work in mathematics is
they say let me kind of think about
things mathematically
i'd come up with an idea and then i'll
try and prove this idea maybe i'll use a
computer
to check some things that i did and so
on but there's a really different way of
doing mathematics
which is to say let's just use the
computer go discover things
just go go sort of experiment about the
mathematical world and try and discover
things you know you're
investigating prime numbers what's this
you know distribution of these types of
primes with this thing
let's see if we can notice some
something when we do computer
experiments on that
let's see if when we study this system
that involves these functions that apply
to these functions
and we just try it in all possible ways
like for example right now
i have a computer experiment running
that uh um
i don't know whether we'll finish by the
time i'm i'm done with this uh
uh this session but but um um i have a
computer experiment running
that's trying to figure out whether uh
certain compositions of these combinator
things that i happen to have been
studying recently
are capable of doing some particular
thing and that's something where i could
say
oh well let me try and mathematically
prove it i don't know how to do that
i can imagine you could do it it's just
rather difficult but instead i'm just
saying okay computer just go do the
experiment once i see the results of the
experiment
then maybe i'll say aha it's obvious
that this had to work that way
but the thing is to use the computer to
do the experiment
um to um
to find out what's true and the thing
that's remarkable in mathematics is
there's still an awful lot of kind of
low-hanging fruit of things that are
um kind of pretty elementary questions
that uh once you ask them you can do the
computer experiment you find out what's
true
and then you can kind of then the
challenge is a different challenge you
know what's true you just did the
computer experiment
maybe you only know a million cases and
you know it works in a million cases you
don't know
works in every case but you have some
pretty good evidence
then the question is you know is that
mathematics you know you came up with
some mathematical conclusion
but to sort of make it connect to
ordinary mathematics you kind of have to
make this bridge
between the things your computer
discovered and kind of the
the math that sort of the typical math
book would have in it
but i think the thing that is
interesting is you have a fantastic
advantage
because you know what's true from just
having the computer do the experiment
and figure it out
and that's something that is
surprisingly i mean even after all these
years
something which is very rarely done in
mathematics some of the great
mathematicians
in history in fact worked that way they
had to do it by hand rather than by
computer
some great mathematicians today use
computers i'm happy to say usually our
software
to be able to to do those kinds of
experiments right now
um but uh but it's a rare thing for
people to do and it's a great
opportunity for people who
kind of understand computational things
to be able to kind of figure out stuff
in math so then the question then is
becomes not what can you figure out
but what should you try to figure out
what are the questions you want to
answer
so i think then the thing to do is well
you know you can start riffing
on some class that you're doing i don't
know what kind of classes you're doing
but um i i don't know let me give you a
random example it comes to mind
okay let's say you're doing calculus
class well and let's say they tell you
do these integrals do these integrals
it's they're very difficult they're all
kinds of tricks
for doing these integrals okay so here's
a question
so if you just look at just tons of
integrals of this type
what's the probability that this
integral is doable
in terms of some class of functions now
i bet nobody ever asks that question
um i mean in in in that form and you
know
but with a computer you can just go see
you know you go type it into
you know to or language even more from
alpha
um although you have to do it more
systematically than that
uh you know you know you don't want to
be typing in every single one by hand so
to speak
um but you know you just say well all
functions of the form log log log
whatever
you know what fraction come out in this
way what fraction come out in that way
what are the possible forms that are
generated can you
deduce can you for example find a
heuristic for guessing
uh whether it's going to come out in
simple form or not there are big
mathematical theorems there's a thing
called rush's theorem
which is a theorem that tells one things
about given a particular form of
integrand
um and given a what kinds of of things
can appear in the integral
and what in what structure and so on but
you know that's just a
i just off the top of my head that's
just a very elementary kind of case
to look at is you know you you learn
integrals and you do a bunch of
integrals
in particular by hand you know for your
calculus class
but it's like well what's you know
what's the whole space of integrals what
does it look like what what kinds of
things happen
uh i mean it's just one one example or
let's say you're doing
probably uh even better hunting ground
if you were doing something like a
number theory class or or something like
that there's there's some
there's all sorts of interesting
questions you know you take a number
and you say oh here's an example you say
you um
uh you're trying to um you think about a
number
as being written as a sum of
digits with powers of ten but there's
other ways to build up a number
you could take other iterated operations
and you could ask questions like
what kinds of iterated operations can
you take can you make
that will give you numbers and will give
you unique representation of numbers
um you know for example if you use
fibonacci numbers instead of
instead of ordinary powers of 10 or
something you know what would you get
that one has been well studied
but if you take something other than
just multiply and add as the operation
to get
to use the next digit what kinds of
representations of numbers are there
well probably a few of those have been
studied i think
there are a few talked about in my new
kind of science book and some note
at the end of that book but there's you
know it's a wide open area
um and and you know that's something
where you can do an experiment
you can come up with a conclusion and uh
yeah it's a piece of research
and maybe some of maybe what you
conclude will be able to be addressed
using the methods that you've learned
in some math class about number theory
or something maybe they'll be
need methods that haven't been invented
yet maybe they're places where you can
say the computer says it's true
but i can't really quite explain using
traditional math
why it's true but still that's a way of
sort of jumping into doing
doing these kinds of research things but
i think the thing is that the question
is really
to sort of hone the creativity of
figuring out what's a good question to
ask
and then to know the methods and tools
well enough to
actually be able to to answer those
questions you know when you have the
question
immediately be able to jump in and say
let me try and figure out what the
answer is
and uh i should probably wrap up here
because um
um it's some uh
uh among other things i am curious
whether i got the answer to um uh to the
question that um
i was having my computer work on let me
see if i can look over at my computer
here
and see whether it looks like a
generated result oh i think i covered
that window so sad um
the uh all right uh a cliffhanger for me
um okay well uh thanks very much for
for joining us and um uh have a happy
remainder of thanksgiving weekend if
you're in the us
and see you again another week